- So I liken it to seeing
a parent with a toddler.
Like if you're at a
restaurant and the toddler
is freaking out and screaming,
and there are the parents that
give a toddler what he wants
and that's like
terrible parenting.
And White America, when they see
these radicalized black people,
'cause it's not
all black people,
but they get the
attention, right?
These radicalized
black people screaming
and wailing about something,
they just give them what they
want no matter what it is.
Defund the police.
Okay, we'll just start talking
about defunding the police
because you've made
that ridiculous,
absurd demand that has
never been made ever.
And so it's hard not to
think that this is actually
the fault of white guilt, right?
This is white
guilt gone too far.
You guys are like overdosing
on white guilt right now.
(warm instrumental music)
- I'm Dave Rubin, and
this is the Rubin Report.
I originally interviewed
Candace Owens on March 12th
to discuss her new
book "Blackout."
But as we recorded news of
COVID related lockdowns began
and suddenly the news
cycle totally shifted.
Now, six months later, we're
picking up the conversation
and then releasing the
original conversation unedited
along with the new pickup
we're doing right now.
Most guests would never
allow an interview
to sit for so long, but
if I can say one thing
about Candace Owens, it's that
she's a woman of her words.
Candace, we shot that interview,
it seems like a lifetime
ago, but it was March 12th.
And it basically was the
day that the lockdowns
were beginning, and the second
we stepped out of the studio,
your assistant, my whole
team, everyone's telling us,
we're freaking out.
You guys had to get out of LA,
but you are a woman true
to your word even now,
six months later 'cause
you were like, eh,
I don't think this is
anything, this is nonsense.
They're trying to
take Trump out.
And from everything I
know of you since then,
you have consistently put
that message out there.
So first off, how are you?
I haven't seen you in
a while, how you doing?
- I'm doing well.
I think it's also important
that I break the story here
that on that day, the morning
I woke up at my hotel,
I had an allergic reaction
to feathered pillows.
So my voice was scratchy
and I had a cold
and I came in and Dave and
his husband did not believe
that I had had an
allergic reaction
and they thought I was COVID-19.
- It wasn't just that you
had an allergic reaction.
You came in, you were
coughing and sneezing.
The news is breaking
all over the world.
And you were telling
us that you had blood,
that you were coughing blood
earlier in the morning.
And then you're like, oh,
you don't mind if I work
from your house all day, do you?
And what did I do?
What does a real friend do?
You did, and we even fed you.
- Yes, but that is what
feathered pillows do to me.
I have the strangest allergy
with feathered pillows.
And if I sleep on one I wake up
and I will literally
be coughing blood
but the timing I
will give you credit,
it was just bad timing
with all the COVID-19 stuff
freaking out so...
- Man, how bad would Vox
love it if Candace Owens was
patient zero on COVID-19?
I mean, come on.
- They would have
loved it so much.
- They would have loved it.
All right, so listen, I said
to you before we did this
that I wanted to do a pickup
with you because it does feel
like a totally different
world in just six months,
it feels so different.
But we are gonna
air that interview
totally unedited just as it was,
but I thought it was worth
talking for another half hour.
So just about what has gone
on for the last six months,
if any of that has
changed your feelings
on anything or anything else.
So first off you are in D.C.
You've become a creature
of the swamp somehow.
What's life like in D.C.?
How has COVID affected you?
And you know, you're pretty
outspoken about this stuff
but are you okay with
any level of lockdowns,
any level of masks, anything?
- I'm not okay with any of it.
You know, I think it's very
easy when people are scared
to convince them to
give up their freedoms.
And we saw that.
I mean, people hardcore,
conservative suddenly like, yes,
we should all be locked down,
force businesses to close.
And it's an act of tremendous
cowardice in my opinion,
for people not to realize that
even in times of a pandemic,
we still have to have
our basic freedoms,
the freedom for if
you are an individual,
and you think that COVID-19
is the bubonic plague,
you should have the freedom
to be able to decide,
to stay at home and lock
yourself in a basement in order,
you know, seamless
and Instacart.
If that's what you want to do.
But you should also allow
me to have the freedom
to open my business and to say,
if you'd like to come
into my business,
you know, I'd love
to host you here.
That's that freedom doesn't
go away because of a pandemic.
And I think people sort
of lost the thread on that
because they were so terrified.
You know, now people have
obviously shifted their opinions
and people are on my side,
I tend to take a very bold
and strong opinion early on
when people are unsure.
But to me it was the entire
Coronavirus narrative
was just too perfect and too
timely in an election cycle,
we have to shut
down the economy.
We had to put
everybody on welfare
and give them stimulus checks.
And you know, nobody
can leave their homes
so they have to rely on the
mainstream media narrative
because they can't go
out and have experiences
with their friends that would
make them say, you know what,
maybe it's not as
scary as it is,
as I've been out to
a party a few times
and I haven't
gotten the illness.
So I never trusted it.
Of course, I think
Coronavirus is real.
What I was questioning was the
idea that it was some plague,
like thing that was
gonna take us all out
if we stepped
outside of our door.
And I really thought it
was about mailing voting
from day one.
- Yeah, and by the way, you
were taking it from both sides,
you kind of touched on this
because you were giving it
to conservatives who were
all about a lockdown suddenly
and you know, government
overreach, let's say.
And then I saw like
the usual suspects,
the Lefty blue check people,
because you dared to go to
whole foods without a mask.
And then there were
several blue check people
that blood is on
your hands Candace,
how many people have you killed?
How many?
- Apparently times for going
to whole foods, they were like,
well, how could
you possibly say,
she goes to whole foods
every day and I'm like, look,
I can't go anywhere
because you shut down
all of my events, I happen
to live near a whole foods
and I like to look
at what they have
at the meat counter every day.
So, you know, at the time
during COVID lockdowns,
I was early in my pregnancy,
so I am an asthmatic.
So I have preexisting conditions
and I ended up deciding
to travel the world
because I was that convinced
of how untrue narrative was.
And I was shocked to
discover the second you step
outside of America,
you realize we're the only
ones playing the crazy game.
And I was in England, there
were no mass mandates.
I went to Croatia.
They have no idea that there's
even a Coronavirus going on.
The kids are running
around freely, no mask,
no social distancing.
So it just felt to me,
especially when I got home,
because I had those experiences
and it was really being
manufactured for Americans.
- All right, so I
wanna ask a question
that I think cuts to the
heart of the Candace Owens
that I know, but is also
the public Candace Owens,
which is those first few days
when everyone was freaking out,
when everyone was
really freaking out
and you just took that
position of this is BS,
this is nonsense,
all of that stuff.
What is it about you?
I've asked you some
version of this before,
because I even remember
seeing your tweets
right at the beginning, and I
was kinda like, oh, Candace,
like, you might really be
stepping in it right now.
You know, if a week later
it turns out that, you know,
half of us have this thing
or everyone over 60 is dead,
but what is it about
you that you just do it?
You just get the thought and
you're just like, I'm rolling.
- You know, I think I have
very good gut instinct.
I just always really trusted
my gut on certain things.
And like I said,
it was too perfect.
And usually if something
seems too perfect,
it's because it's too perfect.
And it was just also
all of the media,
the death ticker was
very strange to me
like we've never
done that before.
I mean, if CNN, MSNBC
did a death ticker
for every time there
was a car accident,
you'd be terrified
to get in your car.
So I was already seeing that
there was a psychological
element that the media was
playing because there was,
it was just very bizarre to see
a death ticker for anything,
of course, you're way more
likely to get into your car
and get into an accident in LA,
but they would never do that.
And so I really felt
that it was just too easy
for them to get into the
minds of so many people.
And I'm so crazy about
not being brainwashed.
And it just, none of it
made sense to me at all.
It just from start to finish,
never thought it made any sense.
- So where do you think
we're at with it right now?
Like do you think Trump
should be doing more
in terms of forcing
states to open
or should he just sit
back and let them all do
what they want or where you at?
- I think if I was the
president of United States,
I would do exactly what he did
in terms of sending it back
down to state, by
state sovereignty,
because it allows people
to really understand
who's running their state.
Depending on what
state you're in,
you know, you're either
living in a communist state
or you're living with freedom.
So you're either
living with, you know,
Rhonda Santos or Gavin Newsome.
And it's important people
to that their leaders
are behind this,
so that they can't just put
it all on the president.
But I do think when he
runs reelected November,
he needs to put a stop
to this immediately.
And I'm already seeing governors
saying that sort of a thing
like Rhonda Santos said,
he will not locked
down to state.
What is predictable is that
there will be a second wave,
which is more deadly.
Right about now,
So we're gonna start
seeing that in October
and they're gonna start
ramping up that rhetoric.
And I think that, you
know, at that moment,
what we need people to start
standing up and saying, no,
and we're seeing that
in other countries
where, you know, they have
been fighting for their rights
and we need to see
more of that in America
because you'll wake up one
day and you won't have any,
and I have not worn a mask.
So I'm very proud of myself.
- Yeah, and I think
it's public knowledge
that you are pregnant.
Right, I don't have
to whisper that?
- Yes, it is public.
- So you're also
six months pregnant
we're obviously
thrilled for you,
but I know you're not going
to do something reckless
with your health or the
health of your baby.
You're doing what
you think is right.
- Right, exactly.
And you know, both of my
sisters happen to have
their first babies, two
little boys in April.
So in the middle of lockdowns,
so I spend time with my family,
spend time with my grandfather
who is the most high risk,
you know, type one
diabetic, he's 75% blind.
He has seen all of his family
members during Coronavirus.
Because even if you are an
old person, you are at risk,
who is the government
to tell you
what you're allowed to value
at the time that you have Left,
the time that you have
Left of your life,
my grandfather values being
with his great grandchildren,
his grandchildren
and his family,
you know, he lost his wife.
Those people have lived
through harder times.
See what I mean?
You're talking about
the real struggle
and you're telling them
they have to stay at home.
It's such foolishness to
not let each individual
to make their own decisions
about their values.
- Do you sometimes think that
your sort of like a proxy
for other people to live
out the sort of boldness
or something that
they wanna live?
'Cause like, if I look at
what people tweet at you
all the time, you
know, a lot of people
obviously say mean things, okay.
But the people that like you,
they're always sort of like,
0h, I can't say all
this stuff in my life,
but like Candace just says it.
So something like Corona,
I think a lot of people
are even right now
really afraid to say anything,
close to what you're saying.
- Yeah, you know, they
definitely have come out.
I've gotten so many emails.
Like, I'm so sorry
I doubted you.
And now I see how they're
fluffing the numbers
or how none of it makes sense.
And all of these scandals
are happening all over.
And I hope that people see
me as a source of inspiration
in terms of just being
yourself and being audacious.
And, you know, to an extent,
I know when I first came out,
I'll never forget the
conversation with Sam Harris.
He was like, and bless him.
But he was like, this
is world war three.
Like he was like, you all
need to be in our bunkers.
Y'all need to stay away.
This is the end of the world.
And, you know, had it just
pounding you with all of these
facts and people that he knew.
And I think sometimes
people can be so smart
that they don't rely
on their gut instincts.
And you know, I hope
that I challenged people
to understand that information
is constantly being manipulated
to make us believe one
narrative or the other.
And sometimes it is best to
trust in your gut instincts.
And I'm definitely a gut player
and it's served me pretty well.
- Yeah, by the way,
if I'm not mistaken,
the little thing
between you and Sam
that was started publicly,
and I think you
reached out to me,
you made a point of it and
I was able to coordinate
so you guys could talk privately
instead of doing
everything publicly.
And we talk about
that all the time.
When we see people we know
go after each other publicly,
and it's like, why
didn't you text me?
You could just call me.
Maybe, I dropped the ball
on this one, you know.
- Right, if you say that
people can, if in fact,
check me on this, I
have never publicly
gone after a conservative that
has not gone after me first.
And I go after them
because I hate that.
Exactly what you're saying,
that I'm responding.
'Cause I'm like every
single one of you
has a way to reach me.
We have mutual
friends, it's a small,
tight knit, conservative circle.
So when I see people that are
tweeting something about me,
or at me, I know they're
doing it for their own ego
and for clicks,
not because they actually
wanna have a resolution
and to Sam's credit,
he tweets something at me
and then immediately privately
said, let's hop on the phone.
And we had a discussion
and I hung up the phone
and was like, you know,
we're just on opposite sides
of this thing, you know?
And that's fine too.
That's totally fine.
But you know, he
thought that my tweets
were so responsible and they
were gonna get people killed
and I felt otherwise.
And I said, you know,
we're gonna have to ride this
thing out because we disagree.
But I do think there
needs to be a bit more
of an adult approach on the
conservative side in general.
Like I'm never trying to
go after you, claws on.
if I disagree, I'm happy to
have a private conversation
with you.
- Yeah, all right.
Well, let's talk
about the other thing
enough about COVID.
Racism, Candace.
It's everywhere.
There's more of it to go
around than ever before.
It's a miracle that they even
let you use Skype right now
as a black woman.
I mean, what do we do
about this situation?
- I mean, I think
it is really time.
The challenge now is to
just dear white people,
what the hell have
you been thinking,
allowing this to go on this far?
You know what I mean?
At this tail in
between the legs,
hey look, my ancestors,
I can at least say,
we were dragged with chains
and whipped and beaten
into submission
white people today,
I don't even know what this is.
This is crazy.
I mean, I've never
seen such people
that are just so willing
to fight for their own
oppression, right?ú
To say, oh, I
shouldn't deserve it.
I just stepped down from my job.
I shouldn't be in this room.
I shouldn't be able
to say anything.
I should be silent for a day.
And it is just such an
openly hostile okay society
in terms of treating
White people poorly.
And, but White people
have dug the graves.
So it's very bizarre to me.
And you know, I liken it to
seeing a parent with a toddler.
Like if you're at a restaurant
and the toddler's freaking
out and screaming,
and there are the parents that
give a toddler what he wants
and that's like
terrible parenting.
And white America,
when they see these
radicalized black people,
'cause it's not
all Black people,
but they get the
attention, right?
These radicalized
black people screaming
and wailing about something,
they just give them
what they want,
no matter what is,
defund the police, okay.
We'll just start talking
about defunding the police
because you've made
that ridiculous,
absurd, demand that has
never been made ever.
And so it's hard not to
think that this is actually
the fault of white guilt, right?
This is white
guilt gone too far.
You guys are like overdosing
on white guilt right now.
- Not me, hey, not me lady.
I'm not guilty for anything,
I haven't done me personally,
but you know.
- And so I always just ask,
please stop giving the toddlers
in the black community,
what they want.
And similarly, I won't
give your, you know,
freakish little and white
thugs what they want,
you know?
And there just needs
to be more people
having a bit of a
spine, I would say,
in the white community.
- Did you sense that
this thing was coming
sort of like what we
were always up against
when we would do
college events together
and it would be this odd
sort of Antifa thing,
but we didn't know
exactly what it was.
And it was a little bit before
BLM had like fully exposed
itself to be, but all of this,
and as I said to you
in our other interview,
and as we've always
done it at every event
we've ever done together, we
take questions from people
who disagree with us first,
but are you shocked how
quickly in the last six months,
this thing like molded
together and BLM and Antifa
and the Marxists
and the Twitter,
like the whole thing
just morphed into one
really evil monster,
really freaking fast,
all sort of under
the COVID thing.
Like it all happened
at the same time.
- Right, I wasn't
shocked, I mean,
I had been warning
about this for years.
I kept saying during
an election cycle,
you're gonna see race
issues drummed up.
Now how violent they'd gotten,
yes, that surprised me.
And also, I would
say I've been shocked
by the permission
they'd been given.
And the excuses in the
past is they've been given
by politicians.
I never foresaw that coming.
I would think a store gets
robbed, looted, torn down,
burned, and you know,
no matter whether you're
left or right, you know,
you would stand up and
say, this is wrong.
The inability for politicians
to now acknowledge what's
right and what's wrong,
that has shocked me.
We put a real low point
when people are saying,
this is okay, when politicians
don't have the spine to say,
you know what, I'm actually
not okay defunding the police.
And we need to
isolate this incident
and incompatalise this incident
and not say that every
police officer was wrong.
And so I am shocked at how
much the Left hates America
and how much the Left hates
people that do the right thing,
because that's really
what it's come down to.
If you do the right thing, if
you earn accolades in life,
if you climb the ladder
in life, they hate you.
And they're saying, there's
not a place for you anymore.
There's something fundamentally
wrong with free market,
with capitalism, with
everything that America
and in Western ideals
and Western principles
were built upon.
So that part shocked me,
but not this narrative.
I was seeing it
everywhere I went
and I knew that
they were organized,
that they were well-funded
and that they were gonna
come ready to fight.
- Yeah, how do you see any
chance of getting of this thing?
I mean, as you said,
you expect Trump to win.
I think you would think
he's gonna win big.
I think he's probably
gonna win big too.
And it's like, no matter if
Biden wins, if Trump wins,
if Biden wins big, if Trump
wins big, it's sort of like,
I don't see a way we get
out of this either way.
I could see some version
maybe where if Trump wins
by truly a landslide, like a
Reagan re-election situation
that maybe finally the
last few decent Democrats
get the kids out
of the adult table.
Like the kids that
they've let taken over
that sort of what you
were saying before.
Maybe they do it themselves,
but that doesn't seem
very probable to me.
Do you see any way we
get out of this thing?
- Well, the only way we
get out of it is if people,
and I think we are actually
are starting to get out of it
now in a weird way, because
people are starting to see
socialism manifest, right?
Marxist principles manifest.
They're looking around
their neighborhoods
and they're seeing, you
know, stores being looted,
stores being robbed,
violence happening,
police getting shot,
individual cities that
are gone up in crime
by something like 267%,
right in New York city
and in Chicago.
And they're seeing
that the suburbs
are now being threatened.
They're gonna come
to the suburbs,
they're telling people in the
suburbs to leave their house.
You saw I'm sure the video clip,
maybe you didn't
'cause you were away,
but throughout DC, they were
going up to white people
at restaurants and saying,
put your fist up and say,
you know, black power or
else you get screamed at.
So these people are now
seeing you've supported this
and now you've seen
what it's become.
And I think that once
those people understand,
once they see that manifest
they'll change their perspective
and they'll vote
differently, right?
And then of course,
once the Democrats,
if the Democrats
lose a ton of seats,
it no longer serves
them to be funding
these Marxism 'cause it
no longer serves them
to stand behind the
violent criminals,
it no longer serves
them to pretend
that these criminals
were righteous
and you'll see a dramatic
change to society.
And I think that it will
secure as it did in England.
If I'm hoping to see
what we saw in England,
where after Blexit,
it just, every vote
went to the Tory party.
I think that we will see
the same thing in America.
And we'll save this country
for a lot of time to come
because people will
not forget this.
- Yeah, I sense
you're kind of right.
You know, I hate when they
say the gay community,
the black community, the
community thing, I hate that.
But you know, I saw this poll
just since I've been back
that at one point, I
guess post the convention,
24% of black people were
thinking about voting for Trump.
Historically, we're
looking at like 4%,
you know, I tweeted
something like a year ago
that I thought Trump was gonna
get 30% of the black vote.
And I know that might
be a little crazy,
but I still, I think that
the mask has been pulled off
and I think something crazy
is gonna happen, I really do.
Are you with me on that?
- A hundred percent, you know,
I've been saying this forever.
And I was laughed at,
in the beginning, right?
When I first said blackshit
and I said that my vision had
always been 20 points by 2020.
I knew it was possible
because the Left can no
longer hide from itself.
And I was so happy
when AOC hit the map
because she was just saying
it, you know what I mean?
The old school Democrats were
a bit hiding what they wanted.
And then AOC kind of
took over their party
and said, no, this
is what we want.
And they capitulated
to what she was saying.
And so they couldn't
lie anymore, right?
They couldn't lie about the
fact that they were supporting
these Marxist principles and
the destruction of family,
Black Lives Matter
on the website,
destruct the nuclear family.
You know, this is wrong,
this is backwards.
So, and I've just
seen so many people,
people you least suspect that
have contacted me privately
celebrities, that
you would just go,
this person posted
a black square.
This person is a
Marxist and just going,
I've had an awakening
and I would like to have
a private conversation
with you offline.
And I think that that's me.
It's just made me
feel just so happy.
Like all of this, all the
beatings that I've taken,
it hasn't been for nothing.
- Yeah, well, so I think I
asked you this six months ago,
so I may be asking you
the exact same question
from six months ago
in the same interview.
But since some time has passed,
we both know what the
publishing world is like.
And it takes a long
time to get a book out.
And as you said, because the
COVID you guys delayed it
and you want it to be able
to promote it properly,
and the rest of it.
Are you totally confident that
everything that you laid out
in "Blackout" that these
extreme circumstances
and the strange time
that we live in,
it's not gonna alter
any of the things
that you were writing about?
Do you feel like it's
all timeless enough?
- Yeah, and I actually
added a chapter
because of, you know,
my George Floyd video,
which got something
like 200 million views,
100 million views
just on Facebook.
And I wanted to double
and triple down everything
that I said in that video
and really talk about
what the Black Lives
Matter movement is.
And just remind people
who tried to bully me
out of having that perspective
that I meant when I meant.
And I said what I said, and
that chapter that I added
was really just about
culture, black culture,
that we've done this and would
Cypress take responsibility
that our culture is broken
that we have music
that's broken?
And that we are
encouraging people
to believe in this
gang lifestyle
and the stripper lifestyle
and this baby mama lifestyle.
And it's time to stop
blaming white people
and realize that we've
done this to ourselves.
And we're the only people
that can dig ourselves
out of this hole.
- Yeah, and people seem
to be waking up to it.
So I'm guessing you're
not a huge fan of WAP.
I just heard about WAP,
I'm a little behind.
- Well, yes.
I don't think you and I will
be coordinating a dance to that
anytime soon,
unless you want to.
- You've seen me dance.
It won't be pretty actually,
literally the last time I
danced it was at your wedding
and it's probably the
last time I'll dance
for the next year anyway.
So it seems like, I
mean, I can tell...
I said to you right before
we started the recording,
you sort of have that
pregnant glow to you,
but you seem like
particularly happy to me,
which, you know,
these days, everyone,
when I was off the grid and
people would recognize me
or come up to me, or if
someone came to my house,
everyone would say, oh,
Dave, it's so much worse.
It's so much worse.
And it struck me how depressed
people are by the news.
You know, I try to...
I take this stuff seriously
and I know it's serious,
but I also do try to
separate myself from it.
That's why I do
the August thing.
But you get a ton
of hate, as I said,
you get a ton of love,
but like, you
really do seem happy
in the midst of all of this,
which I think is probably
weird for some people to see.
- I'm so happy, it's crazy.
I wake up every day and I'm
like, I'm the happiest person.
And it can seem totally bizarre.
But my perspective is just
that all I've ever wanted
was for in this crazy
game of political poker,
for the Left to just lay
down all of their cards
and show us their hands
and they're doing that.
And so there's this
quickening happening right now
where people are starting
to finally understand
my perspective of
so many other people
that have been
fighting alongside me.
I mean, on top of
that, I have a husband,
you know, that I love,
you know, I've
recently got married,
I'm having a baby, I'm having
the easiest pregnancy ever.
I work out all the time
and I'm just happy vibes
all the time.
And I right now also am sensing
bizarrely that even amidst
all of the different
conservative connections
that we're all starting
to bond a bit better.
And we're starting to understand
that we all have
different strategies,
but us fighting and
pulling each other,
wasn't really working.
And I just sense more unity
in the conservative movement
and more focus, which
I'm thrilled about.
And so I just have
nothing to be upset about.
I truly am the happiest person.
I'm just like, guys,
it's all gonna be fine
we're fighting, we're
on the good guy side.
The good guys always win so.
- The good guys always win.
Well, listen, Candace,
we could do a lot more,
but I actually think
that's the perfect moment
to just give people the other
hour that we did together.
And it stands on its own,
but I just wanted to
chat with you anyway.
So that's why we
did this mostly.
- Guys never forget that
when I was coughing blood,
my friend wanted me to
get tested for COVID-19.
(both laugh)
- Excuse me, Dave
Rubin made you eggs,
made you eggs, when
you didn't know
where you were gonna
sleep that night.
That really, I mean,
people can understand.
It's not just that
you were telling me
you were coughing up
blood, but you're coughing,
you're sneezing, we're watching
the NBA season got canceled.
I think right then
I saw the video.
And then your assistant
was with us too.
And she's coughing
and she's sneezing.
And they're telling us
we're all gonna die.
And I let you stay till
about nine o'clock at night.
- You did indeed, that's
a true friend guys.
- There you go,
Candace, it was great
seeing you as always,
we're gonna play the
full interview now,
and I hope to see you in
real life one of these days,
I think we're gonna
make it happen.
- Sounds good, guys.
Enjoy the interview.
- How long has it been?
It's been about since
the original interview.
- Did I launch in
2017, you did it like,
you were one of my
first interviews.
You and Paul, Joseph
Watson were my first two.
So I think that was 2017.
- Yeah, so let's say
it's about three years.
You were on the show one other
time for some other thing,
we'll just let that
one be for now.
Not important to
get into that one.
Some people probably know
what I'm talking about,
but doesn't matter.
But yeah, so it's
been about three years
at the time we were
doing YouTube week here
and I just tweeted out,
I need to find some YouTubers
that are interesting.
I wanna do five shows with
five different YouTubers
in five days, blah, blah, blah.
A couple of people said, you
got to check out Red Pill Black
We watched your first video,
which was sort of about
announcing to your family,
that you're a conservative that
kind of caught you on fire.
We brought you in here.
It feels like another
lifetime ago, doesn't it?
- 'Cause it was, it definitely
was a another lifetime ago.
It's totally bizarre
to consider it
that was just three years ago.
And how much has gone on
and how much has changed
and how much I've changed,
how much I've grown and
things that I've learned.
And I feel like what I was
sitting across from you
those years ago, I was so naive
to what I was about to be
thrown into the middle of
for better or for worse,
I was naive and now
I'm much more seasoned,
much more experienced and
much more sure of myself.
- How have you managed to
stay sane through the machine?
So, 'cause yeah, you
really were just, I mean,
kid in a certain way,
like I feel like we were kids
and it's only three years ago
and it's not like we're 18,
but we were sort of
kids in this thing.
You started just saying
what you thought.
One of the moments we've
discussed this many times
privately, where I was like,
oh, Candace is the real deal.
Is there was a question
that I asked you
about this surveillance state
in that first interview.
And you basically said,
I don't have an opinion.
I need to know more.
And I was like, well,
nobody does that.
That's what you're supposed
to make up some shit.
But you actually said that.
And I thought, this is someone
who will learn going forward.
- I think that's definitely
what separated me
from other people.
I've just remained
really authentic.
I'm not trying to be an
expert on everything.
I've been honest about the
fact that I'm learning.
And I say now that I've pretty
much grown up politically
in front of everybody's faces,
they've seen my awkward braces,
due to the analogy,
my brace phase,
the pimple phase of
me being in politics.
And there were things that
I genuinely did not know.
I had never heard of because
I spent my entire life
not being politically inclined.
And then suddenly
I'm on your show
because I just had a feeling
more than a fact, right?
I had a feeling that black
Americans were being duped
and that none of
it really added up,
none of it made any sense.
And I wanted to convert
those feelings into facts
and start really doing
the work and studying.
And some people wanted to push
me as, now you're a leader,
you must know everything when
I wasn't ready to do that.
And other people were
trying to make me stand by,
Google through these
Puritan tests, if you will,
that the Puritan Conservatives.
And then I have the Left
trying to destroy me,
the Puritan Conservative,
trying to prove that I wasn't
what I was, I guess,
held up to be.
And it was crappy,
it was really crappy.
'Cause I'm sitting
here going guys,
I'm literally just telling
you, I've been authentic,
I haven't said that people
should be following me over,
you know, into another
area or anything like that.
But I survived it because I'm
authentic and I wasn't scared.
I was never scared to be myself.
- Why not?
Not scared to be yourself,
but why weren't you
scared by the attacks?
Like when Twitter
puts their lead story
is basically, you
know, on the search bar
was like, you know,
something like
Candace Owens is all right,
which eventually they took
down after you respond.
'Cause you always punched back.
But what do you think it
is about you specifically
that, you know, 'cause a lot
of people fear this thing,
they know who they
are, they wanna fight,
but they just fear the monster.
- You know, I think for
me, what's really aided me
is perspective.
So I've had people they're
all stressed out about Twitter
and Facebook and
all of these things.
And to me, I think
first and foremost,
being someone that
came from nothing,
you know, a person that
was not raised in a family
that had any financial
means who grew up poor.
My perspective is
a bit different.
And I think to myself,
if the biggest
complaint I have today
is that I'm trending on
Twitter about something
that I didn't say or were
taken out of context,
then I'm remarkably blessed.
A couple of generations ago,
my grandfather
was picking cotton
and laying out tobacco dry
on a sharecropping farm.
I couldn't look him
in the face and say,
I've had a really stressful day
because I'm trending on Twitter
and that's not what I said.
It's just perspective.
Yeah, you have to...
And I also have a tremendously
good sense of humor.
- Yeah, you do, you do.
Well, what is the part of you
that is actually political?
'Cause you don't
really strike me,
like when we hang
out separately,
like we always talk politics,
but we talk about a
lot of other stuff
and it's usually cultural what
we're really talking about.
But you're thought of as
like this political beast,
like, Candace is gonna
be president or again,
is gonna be a Senator.
You know, something like that.
- I mean, I remind people
of what Andrew Breitbart
said about politics is
downstream from culture.
It's such an important thing.
He's so accurate with that.
The reason why things
weren't changing
and conservative ideas
weren't winning in society
is because conservatives
by and large
stuck up their nose to culture.
And I say that as somebody
who had to go through the
conservative ring of fire too.
People know obviously the
Left routinely attacks me
and that they've attacked me
since I started
making YouTube videos,
but they forget that
conservatives attacked me too.
You know, one of the
first hate pieces
that was written about me,
was written by the
National Review
and I'll never
forget the sentence.
This is the sort of conservatism
that we need to reject
is what they wrote.
This is the sort of...
Because I was
making funny videos,
'cause I was making people
understand big concepts,
because I wasn't writing
a 95 thesis, you know,
95 thesis and stapling
it to a wall and saying,
here you go guys.
- Right you weren't
in a think tank
funded by a gagillion dollars
- Yeah, I was just on YouTube
taking some complex topics
and being conversational
and that same kind of
vein of conservatism
or the people that thoroughly
rejected Donald Trump.
Donald Trump is cultural,
he takes complex topics
and he dilutes them down
to something that
feels tangible.
That somebody who's
a normal individual,
that's a hard worker can
understand #lockherup.
Right, he's saying a
lot in there, right?
There's corruption that's
been going on for a long time.
Something needs to change.
It's a swamp, right?
People hate how
colloquial that is,
but people will respond to
a more colloquial manner
and how I speak, I don't
speak to my cousins,
like I'm giving a thesis paper.
I talked to them
conversationally and
that was my style.
- But Candace as someone
that's had dinner
with that Trump guy and
has been to The Oval Office
and done other things
with that Trump guy,
I thought he hates black
people, I saw on CNN.
He's a racist and a homophobe.
- It's crazy and I think
it's fortunate that the media
continually
overplays their hand.
It's fortunate because it's
the reason that I exist.
And anybody who has a
modicum of intelligence
knows that this man has been
in the media for decades.
He was never accused of being
racist, sexist, bigoted,
homophobe, none of those things.
And then suddenly he runs
for president United States
and he's all of those things.
So for me, it just gave
me pause and I just said,
this can't be right.
I, by no means in that moment,
when it came on, the escalator
thought he should be
president of United States.
But I also wasn't
dense enough to believe
that as he came
down that escalator,
he suddenly became the literally
Hitler white supremacist
that CNN, MSNBC tried
to turn him into.
So I appreciate the media
and them constantly smearing
and libeling people because
I think that it's actually,
it's working in our favor
and it's working on
the side of truth
because more people are
questioning their relationship
with the media.
- So how does someone like you
balance the identity politics
that you hate that
we constantly mock
versus as you always say to me,
you just want black people
to think for themselves
or have black people realize
they don't have to be Democrats.
So there it is twined with
identity politics, right?
Blexit is twined with it.
And I always say, when
people ask me this,
I have to use their
rules against them,
sort of something like that.
But how do you balance that?
- Well, I think it's
understanding the difference
between identity and
identity politics.
So I am happy to be black.
I think black can
be an identity.
I think Jewish can
I think a part of your identity
can be if I was pregnant
and I wanted to take
a class and sit around
with a bunch of pregnant moms
and talk about the struggles
that we're going through,
that's not identity politics,
that's all of us coming together
because we share a
certain identity.
And we're talking
about certain things
that are relevant to us,
black Americans convening
to talk about things
that are relevant for them
is not identity politics.
If I was using Blexit
and at our Blexit events,
we were saying, you need to
vote for Donald J. Trump.
You need to stop
being a Democrat
and start being a Republican.
That would be identity politics
because of the
color of your skin.
It's quite the opposite.
We're talking about why
the color of our skin
and the dialogue, and the
race dialogue is meaningless.
We're talking about
taking responsibility
for things that are going
on amongst our communities
that we have been the
perpetuators of, you know,
we talk about police
brutality in a real context,
we talk about that weighed
against black on black crime.
I think the only way that
black community gets fixed
is if the black community
sort of realizes
that we do have an identity
that we've made a lot of errors
that we continue to
make a lot of mistakes,
and we say, you know what,
it's time for us to stop
blaming the white man.
It's time for us to
stop looking externally
and to start looking internally
and how we can
make a difference.
- So when you see Trump
do the State of the Union
and he talks about the
lowest black unemployment
all the time, and immediately
the headlines say, no, no, no,
that was because of Obama.
Which even if perhaps some
of that is true, perhaps,
well, the guy didn't wreck it.
So that seems pretty good.
But more importantly, that
when you see the congressional
black caucus and they sit
there with their arms folded
over the lowest old
time black unemployment,
now that, something
doesn't add up there.
- Right, and it doesn't
add up because when Obama
gave his State of the
Union and he announced
more food stamps
and more welfare,
they stood up and they applauded
that got a standing ovation.
So that's the kind of
stuff that you can just use
to ask black
Americans, why is that?
Why did Rashida leave, walk
out when Trump announced
that less people were filing
for welfare and food stamps,
she said, she walked
out and she said
they were having
something taken from them
and she just couldn't bear
anymore and she walked.
- Well, she also said
impeach the motherfucker
the day that she got elected.
I mean, literally so it's like,
was this a fair judge
of what's going on here?
- Right, and what
you realize is that
what they want for
black Americans
is to be a permanent underclass.
They need black
Americans to be dependent
upon the government.
And that's just the truth.
And we are dependent
upon the government.
By and large, we are
dependent upon the government.
We've allowed the
government to come in
and father our
families, you know,
with the Great Society
Act in the 1960s,
systematically removing
black men from the home
and making black women bitter.
And that's an interesting thing
and one that I haven't
talked about enough,
but people always
ask me, you know,
what are some of the issues
facing the black community?
We're not a community.
We don't know how
to communicate.
We don't know how to
do conflict resolution,
especially black women.
And you know, this
whole stereotype of
an angry black woman,
where does that
really come from?
I've been having those sorts
of early conversations.
Well, it comes from the
fact that black women
have had to do
things by themselves
because they've allowed
the government tell them
that they should be doing
things by themselves.
And after decades of allowing
this whole baby daddy,
a phenomenon to break out
into our communities, right?
And now we're saying to men,
they don't need
to be responsible
because the government will
step in and give us more money
if they're not
inside of the homes,
you have this, this new epidemic
where you have, you know,
black women that are upset.
They can't really pinpoint
why it is that they're upset
and nothing's really changing
and nothing's really
been productive.
So there's so much that's
fractured in my community
that has nothing to do with
white man, the Jewish man,
Hispanic men, nothing.
We have accepted government
as our source and our solution
for everything and
simultaneously broken
apart our families.
- So one of the things that
I think you've explained
really well, which
is right off that
is that generally again,
the black community,
which is a bit of
an amorphous term,
generally, actually the values
usually do lean
more conservative.
And it's only through
sort of media tricks
that they don't realize
that something like that.
Can you talk about
that a little bit?
- Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, we're
naturally conservative.
I mean, even when all of
the candidates were running
and people were trying to take
Pete Buttigieg'e
judge, seriously,
and I immediately said,
this is all a farce,
pretending that
Buttigig'e the judge
is going to be the presidential
candidate for the Democrats
is a joke because
he's gay, right?
And he's a gay married man.
And that he's
running as a Democrat
and the Democrats
need the black vote.
The black community will not
vote for a gay, married man
to be the candidate.
That's just a fact
whether people like that,
it makes them uncomfortable,
it doesn't mean anything.
- So is that a religious
thing, you think--
- It's tethered to
Christianity, absolutely.
And black people
are deeply faithful
and every poll
showed that, right?
And you saw the Left ignoring
that piece of evidence.
Oh, well, we're not gonna look
at the fact that Black people
are pulling very low and
then they're not okay
with the fact that he's
married to a black man
because they don't
want to accept reality.
So that first and
foremost, right?
So on the LGBT stuff,
the black community
is fiercely, fiercely,
fiercely, conservative,
especially when it comes
to the trans stuff,
there was a remarkable
video of a black pastor.
And it doesn't, you can't
see what he's looking at,
but there's a congregation.
And he looks straight down
at the man and he says,
you need to leave this
church when you come in,
I don't care what you do
outside of this church,
but when you come
here on Sundays,
you come dressed as a man.
And to be speaking to you,
obviously a trans individual man
that was wearing a dress
or dressed as a woman,
and he kicked him
out of the church
and the entire black
congregation started
applauding, right?
That is the black community
on LGBT issues, right?
If you ask me---
- What would you like to see,
would you like to see
something change there?
I mean, as someone that I know,
you have a lot of gay friends,
we're friends and by the way,
I completely
separate the T thing,
the trans thing
from the gay thing.
But what would you
like to have in that?
- I think that what I'm
talking about right now,
it's just the reality in
terms of like not black people
leaning more
conservatively, naturally.
But 100%, I hope that
the black community
is at the forefront of
standing up to the trans stuff.
I never wanna see that change.
And I think that it is
incumbent upon the gay community
to expel it.
You take the T off or we're
not playing the game, right?
If you're saying that now
this is a package deal,
and that somehow you
being a married gay man
means that in order
for me to accept that,
I have to also take drag queens
and men that are
dressed as women
and them being allowed to
go into women's restrooms,
no, I'm not playing the game.
- Well, the other part
that I hate about it
is that I have no more
insight into what it is like
to be a trans
person than you do.
You know what I mean?
I am in the body, I
am supposed to be in.
- They have nothing
to do with each other.
That you're talking
about sexual preference
versus a mental disorder.
A mental disorders the
right way to call it.
If you're telling me your mind
and your physical are
out of order, right?
That that is a mental disorder.
Whether you want to call
it a physical disorder
or mental disorder, it
is a disorder, right?
And to conflate that
with a sexual preference,
which doesn't impact me, right?
But does you being married
to a gay man, impact me?
- You've been here
for many nice dinners.
- It doesn't impact me.
And does me being married to
a straight man impact you?
Okay, but if
suddenly, like I said,
a part of you accepting the
fact that me and my husband
are married means that you
have to also accept the fact
that you know, your child is
now going to be exposed to men,
dressed as women and be
read to by a drag queen
and over-sexualized
and all of this stuff
that comes with the trans
movement, which I view as evil.
I really do.
It's something that
I'm very opposed to.
That's what I see is
where it gets problematic.
And there needs to
be more gay people
speaking out against
it and saying that
we're not just gonna let you
put this on our wagon, right?
And so, I mean, that's something
that I'm passionately against
and I've been against it
since I've been on your show.
- Yeah, well, Douglas Murray,
who I know you've talked to.
I mean, he's and who
happens to be gay,
I mean, I think he's
really led the charge,
the books over here
somewhere where he separates
these two things.
They just have nothing
to do with each other
just to clean all of that up
for the people that
will clip this and go,
oh, Candace hates trans people.
How would you, like if a trans
person that worked at a place
that you work at,
or a trans person
that you met on the street or
had coffee with or something,
how would you like
them to be treated
under the law and
the rest of it?
- They should be
always be protected.
And this concept of like,
because I don't want
to now adapt my life
to the way that you
prefer to lead yours
now means that I somehow think
that you should be harmed
or hurt, no, this is America.
You should be afforded
the exact same protections
I'm afforded to
under the law, right?
But if I woke up one day and
said that I was Superman,
and I said, now all of a sudden
we have to legislate the fact
that I think I'm Superman,
That's crazy.
I mean, we have to accept
that there are various other
disorders too, in this world,
there are mental
disorders in this world,
people that suffer from
schizophrenia, bipolar,
all of these things,
the difference is that we
encourage them to get help.
And we don't demand that the
whole world pretend and shift
to accommodate their
various illnesses, right?
If somebody is schizophrenic
or somebody is suffering
from split personality disorder,
we don't say, okay,
well, you get two votes
because you think you're
two people, right?
That's the trans argument.
- Patients, patients.
- Patients, you're right.
Give it just a couple of years,
Democrats will be on that too.
But that's the trans argument,
which is that because this
is what I'm going through,
gender dysphoria, which
is very real by the way,
everyone now must adapt.
And we must pretend
that there's 36 genders
when there's just not,
and then to call people
that acknowledge it
and can see reality
for what it is, bigoted
or saying they have a
phobia is just wrong
and it's not an area where
I'm willing to give up
any yards on the football field.
- Yeah, so when you see
Trump addressing, you know,
the employment issues
with the black community,
and you understand that
from your perspective
that the black
community is more,
I hate, I just hate
saying the community word.
It's just--
- Black people, blacks.
- Yeah, but even that, like,
'cause of course there's just
all these different types
of black people, of course.
But by and large or
whatever you wanna call it.
So unemployment down,
he's also doing some stuff
on criminal justice reform.
I mean, we were at, in DC,
we did an event and we went
to the Trump Hotel for a drink
and helped me with the
woman's name that we met,
the woman that he
got out of jail.
- Alice Johnson.
- Alice Johnson, yeah.
I mean, he's done some
pretty good stuff there too.
- He's done some
really good stuff.
And I will say this,
it's great that we're addressing
some of these, you know,
older policies that were put
in place first and foremost,
like the things that
were put in place
by the Clintons themselves,
that definitely did
disadvantaged black men.
And I've realized that
I do see a disconnect.
And this is where I go separate
from a lot of conservatives
on this issue, because I have
found that some conservatives
are hardcore on criminal
justice and they say,
you do something bad, you're
locked up, throw away the key
and you're done with it.
And that to me, shows
that they have not
had much of an
experience with people
that end up in the system.
I do agree that above a certain
age you've committed crimes,
you basically, it becomes
very hard for you to come back
from that.
But when people are young
and they're committing
their first offense,
and it's the first time
they're going into prison,
so much change can happen.
There are circumstances are
usually being led by, you know,
I have uncles I've spent their
lives in and out of prison.
When you're completely
impoverished,
and back is against the wall,
when you don't have
your father at home,
sort of the natural
direction that you trend to,
is towards the streets
'cause you will pursue that
paternity elsewhere, right?
So if you are not getting that
guidance from mom and dad,
because they're not at home
and you're not having dinner
around the table at night,
you're still gonna want
somebody to be the mom and dad.
So that's leads
you to the streets,
that could lead you to culture,
that can lead you to hip hop.
Suddenly Jay Z and
Kanye are mom and dad.
And whatever they're telling
you, if somebody's saying,
grab a gun, go outside.
You think that that's
the direction that
you should be into.
So there's so much that happens
when you talk about
the fatherles problem
that we have in the
black community.
And if you can
get them in prison
and you can make just
small differences
in terms of helping them
transition when they get out,
you know, I've been in
prison for two years,
you're gonna give me
$50 and a bus ticket
and you expect me not
to go back to crime?
Those are the things that
are really important.
And I spent some
time, two years ago,
visiting some prisons and
speaking to the inmates.
And it really woke
me up to that.
Now on the other side of that
and where conservatives
are getting it right,
is that this is not...
You can't make the argument
that because there's a lot
of black people in the system
that the system is rotten.
Black people, we
commit more crimes.
That is just the truth.
We are disproportionately
represented in the prison system
because we are
disproportionately
committing crime.
It goes back to that thesis of,
we gotta be more responsible.
- Yeah, yeah, there's
a lot there, okay.
So why is this stuff so hard
for people to understand?
Do you think, like,
is that purely,
just 'cause of the
cultural aspect
that you just constantly
get the reverse message?
- Yeah, it's not hard
for people to understand.
It's people don't
wanna understand it.
I say now that nobody
ever won an election cycle
on the slogan of be
more responsible, right?
'Cause nobody
wants to hear that.
Nobody wants to hear
and be more responsible.
And that's the truth.
A lot of these things and
these issues that we have,
in society are because people
are not being more responsible
because people are
making bad decisions.
And unfortunately
going back to culture,
yes, we have a culture
that tells us it's okay
to not be responsible.
So it's okay to offset
all of your issues.
It's okay to blame, you
know, external institutions
for the problems that you're
dealing with internally.
So it becomes easy.
And like I said,
looking yourself in
the mirror and saying,
I am bad in this way, or I need
to correct this, it's hard.
And most people just don't
have the humility to do it.
- Do you find it funny
the way they always end up
turning it on themselves too?
So once you use racism or sexism
or homophobia as the tool,
it always ends up
coming back on you.
So like Cory Booker
gets out of the race,
next thing you know, Cory,
Booker's saying that, you know,
it's because of racism.
Elizabeth Warren gets out,
everyone says it's
because of sexism,
but it's like, guys, it
was the Democratic primary.
It was your people.
It wasn't those
evil Republicans.
evil conservatives.
It was your people.
So you're saying your
people are racist?
And actually that is
what they're saying.
And perhaps there's
some truth there.
- Right, and what
they say basically,
is if I don't get what I want,
there's something
bigger happening on.
There's something
bigger going on.
- How sweet is that?
- It's the best thing ever.
And actually, I was just
responding to a tweet
when I came in here,
about the woman
who had that big
mathematical hysterical...
Did you see that on MSNBC?
- Oh, Gay is her last name?
Is it Marcy Gay?
I think it's Marcy Gay
from the New York Times.
- Well was it, 500 million
divided by 300 million
equals 1 million or something.
- Basically Bloomberg
with the 500 million
that Bloomberg spent
on the campaign.
He could've given every
American a million dollars.
And Brian Williams
agreed with him.
And apparently the researchers
and all it's like,
we're in here,
I got a couple of
crew members in there,
but we're just doing our thing.
It's like, nobody's
got no IFB here
with someone telling me numbers.
They have a whole series
of people in there and yes,
500 million could actually
give a million people
to every American 350
a million Americans.
- 350 million Americans so her
math on that is 500 million
divided by 350
million Americans--
- But putting aside
the math mistake,
I don't think that's where
you're going with this.
- Yeah, because
then she tweeted,
I don't know if you saw this--
- Yeah, I saw it, I saw it.
- She's written an article
saying that the racist mob
is not going to stop her because
she had to endure racism because
of her mathematical error.
And how pathetic is that?
I mean, really think about that.
This is what really
frustrates me.
This whole concept of
black people being strong.
Are we acting strong right now?
No, we're acting
pathetic, right?
You can't accept that
people are mocking you
because you did something
that was ridiculous
and embarrassing.
You know, what would be strong?
You owning it and
making fun of yourself.
What would be funny?
You going on Saturday Night
Live and doing a whole skit.
Of you like trying
to calculate things
and being wrong, it
would make you likable.
People would go,
haha, that's the girl.
You know, just, just
laugh at yourself,
have a sense of humor.
We all make mistakes.
You know, we all sometimes
get it completely wrong
or say something ridiculous.
But for you to say, even
something that's small, right?
You make a mathematical error
and you're still able
to transform that
into a moment of racism
because black people
cannot be wrong in anything.
Even when they're literally,
factually,
mathematically, incorrect,
it's because people are racists.
- And it's such a trap door too,
because Brian Williams came
off looking as ignorant
and confused as she did.
But Brian Williams didn't
make an excuse for it,
you know what I mean?
And also I quickly glanced
at the Twitter feed
when she posted the
New York Times article.
And it was like, people
weren't calling her race.
There was nobody
saying anything racist.
Nobody was saying,
oh, that black woman
is stupid because she's black.
Like there was
nothing like that.
It was like, it was basically
like you're both idiots.
Like there was a lot of that,
not to say that no racist
person got in there
and said something.
Lord knows that,
I'm sure they did,
but like the knee
jerk response to go,
Oh my get out of
jail, free card,
Is this.
- Is race.
Right, and what it really
speaks to is the fact
that I really believe that
in this moment in time,
black people are
looking pathetic,
that the people that we
have leading culturally,
look pathetic.
This whole, you know, Jussie
Smollett is pretending.
He's launching racist
attacks on himself.
Hiring big black men.
I mean if you're
gonna pay to do it,
pay some white guys 'cause
the police will go with it.
So when we see the images,
it looks like you maybe
thought it was white people
that were doing this to you,
but it's happening
more and more.
And another example of that is
there was a young black girl.
And I can't think of
her name at the moment
who said that white boys
attacked her in school.
It was Karen Pence's
school that she teaches at
and they cut off her dreadlocks
and they called
her racial slurs.
The entire thing
was made up, right?
What bothers me
about that situation
of that young black
girl doing that,
is that it's not
her fault, right?
She is now being raised
in an environment
where black people are
aspiring to victimhood, right?
She's seeing her idol.
She's seeing the Karla Camposes,
the Jussie Smollet,
the, whoever this is
that wrote for the New York
Times, aspire to victimhood
like you get an
award at the end.
Like you get a trophy.
And this is an amazing thing.
You get to be a victim and
you get to be a star now
because everyone's
gonna come behind you.
And they're gonna
feel bad for you.
And they're gonna award you.
You're gonna get accolades.
So this poor young girl,
I actually genuinely
my heart hurt for her
because she was so young.
And for her to do that,
there was no other reason
than she's a product of an
environment of black victimhood.
And there's not
enough black Americans
that are able to
take a joke, right?
Just basic things I say
to you, you know what?
I'm not living in
this simulation of
white versus black.
And that's what I think that
is going to be the next natural
generation of black kids.
Just wanting to be a
victim all the time.
- So when you've
gone to Blexit events
and do all of the
things you're doing,
do you sense that that thing
is just basically ready
to crack?
Like when I've seen the videos
of the events that you do,
it's like the joy that is
in that room is incredible.
It's absolutely incredible.
It's way more joyous than if
you were to go to some event
where you'd be up
there going, you know,
the Republicans did this to you
and we're gonna give
you more of this.
Like there's no joy
unrelated to any of that.
And people want to be joyous.
And one of the things,
you always told me
from the beginning
is how pissed you
were that the way that
black people stop being funny
because black people
are naturally funny.
- They're naturally funny.
And that black people,
Jews, naturally funny.
There's something about
going through struggle.
And that gives you
a sense of humor--
- The outsider look.
- Blue collar perspective
and a sense of humor
gets you through tough
times, it really does.
And that was kind of...
We coined the market on
that, on a sense of humor.
And I always talk about
the old standup routines
and Bigger and Blacker is
one that comes to mind,
which is the one I
watched most recently,
just a great--
- It is a perfect--
- It's a perfect stand up.
You know what's
perfect about it?
Because he's so
racist to everyone.
He goes into the first
thing he says is,
yeah, white people are in
the back tonight, right?
And then everyone
starts laughing.
And by the time he's done,
he's insulted black people,
the baby mama drama,
he's insulted white people,
Jewish people, school shootings.
He even went there at that time.
This was in like 1990,
but he starts being like,
oh, that's a white
person crying.
You know what I mean?
Like talk about the differences
between white crimes
and black crime.
- Yeah, he's got
that great line about
he's like people think black
people don't like Jews,
but like, we hate all of you.
- And everyone's laughing.
And it's just incredible
because by the end of it,
you suddenly realize that
you all kind of suck, right?
In your various ways
and you feel closer
and you feel better for it.
That is what humor
is supposed to be.
It was always supposed
to be medicinal.
It was supposed to
be a way of saying
that like your problems
aren't as big as the problems
of the person next to
you, and we all suck.
And this is kind of
the condition of life.
And we're doing this together.
You can't do that
anymore, right?
If he did that skit
today, go back and I mean,
go back and watch it.
He would be canceled before.
I mean, it would be insane.
It would be insane,
he would be canceled before
he got out the first joke.
And they'd be like,
this is not funny.
I can't, white people
in the back tonight?
This is completely
inappropriate.
I mean like, that would
be the critics today.
- Yeah, ah, God, it's
all, it's so nuts.
Or look at what's his name?
That guy, he was
gonna host the Oscars.
Kevin (snapping fingers)
Kevin, what's his name?
- Kevin Hart.
- Yeah, a tweet--
- From years ago.
- More than 10 years ago.
- One joke of gay, whatever.
- Right, and I'll tell you
what's wrong with that.
The bigger issue with that,
the first thing is he
shouldn't have backed down.
And I thought that
that was an example
of black people being pathetic.
He should have stood his ground.
And that's what I love about.
Give me the black
community and that, Dave--
- Dave Chappelle.
- Dave Chapelle.
I love Dave Chappelle
'cause he stands his ground.
He to me is he is saving
black humor right now.
And people won't realize
until his legacy
settles what he's doing.
But aside from that,
remove Kevin Hart
and think about this
next generation of kids.
We were afforded...
Facebook started when I
was in high school, right?
So I got to be a kid,
there was no social media.
My dad had a beeper
when I was growing up,
and I got to be a kid and what
I mean by I got to be a kid,
I got to be a crappy human being
because part of growing
up is experimenting
with being a crappy human being,
is looking you in the face
saying, you know what,
you're fat, right?
I either liked the
way that sounded
or I liked the way
the person reacted.
Okay, I know I was a mean
person, I didn't like that.
Trying when I had
AIM, like, you know,
just something mean to say,
yeah, I can say whatever I want.
And we didn't have the
society who could capture
our old...
God, could you imagine if the
old age AIM chats came back,
they'd be like Candace get's
canceled in third grade
for saying something.
My handle was BratForLife.
Like, you know what I mean?
Like really ridiculous stuff.
But the purpose of growing
up is to experiment
with who you want to be.
And kids are notoriously mean.
They're picking on each other,
they're getting bullied.
And now you're saying
the kids at what you do,
even if it's 20 years ago,
you can get wiped out.
You could say something
in a WhatsApp,
and if it gets pulled out
your chances of employment,
your chances of going
anywhere, you're done,
you're canceled from society.
If people don't realize now
how that's gonna contribute
to depression and suicide,
to me, it's just something
that nobody has
thought about that.
- It's anti-human actually,
because it is your job as a
human to say what you think,
to be who you wanna be.
And they're trying to
model for young people.
No, don't do it.
Well, that's why I
always say, I mean,
that's why you are dangerous.
You tell people the
complete reverse.
- Right, people have
said to me, by the way,
political advice, you know,
Candace, every six months,
you should just go back
and cancel your tweets.
So they're not lingering.
And I go why?
Why would I be, if
someone brought up a tweet
from nine years ago,
I'm gonna be like,
yeah, I changed my mind, right?
I also don't think Barbies
are the coolest thing anymore.
I changed my mind since I
was three years old, right?
Evolution is normal.
- Even with that car,
she's got that cool car,
she's driving to Malibu.
- But people, what
the Left has done
is they've made it seem like
there's something fundamentally
wrong about evolution.
Like it's not
supposed to happen.
We all evolve, we all evolve.
You are not the same person
that you were 10 years ago.
You're not gonna be the
same person in this room
that you're gonna be
10 years from now.
That's a part of
the human condition.
And when you start to
acquiesce that mentality
and you say, I'm gonna
just delete, you know,
I said something in a tweet
that I should have maybe
not, so I'll just delete it.
So I don't have to pay
for it 20 years from now,
you're acquiescing to something
that people will not be able
to survive in the future.
So I keep it up because
if somebody asks
me why I said that,
I would say it doesn't matter
if I said it, the question is,
do I still believe it?
That's the better
question to ask me,
have I evolved
since that opinion?
Not that there's some
harm in having a thought
or having the wrong idea or
being wrong in the first place.
- And by the way, it's
not just your thoughts
that they want you
to worry about.
It's other people that you're
associated with thoughts.
So sometimes scary Candace
Owens tweets something,
and I'll get a text
message from somebody
like a public person,
and they'll say, Dave,
Candace said that, you know,
are you gonna say something?
As if you're my pet, I
keep you in a little bag.
And it's like, oh yes,
I control Candace.
And I have any right
to tell her what to do
with the rest of it.
But even that idea that
it's not just what you say,
it's that now we wanna
keep you really worried
about who you might
be friends with
and who you might
follow on Twitter.
- And I don't play that game.
And by the way, I think
that's also something
that separates me from most
conservatives, you know,
people that go mainstream
and I, for what it's worth,
I've gone mainstream,
I obviously do the big
networks, I've been on Fox News.
They suddenly start
being very careful
about who they associate with.
Like, you have to pretend you
don't speak to certain people
or you don't know certain
people or else, you know,
you might catch it,
whatever it is, right?
And in a case in point,
Paul Joseph Watson was the
first person to have on a show.
You were the second.
And Paul Joseph Watson and
my husband are friends.
So I'm supposed to pretend
because Paul Joseph Watson
used to be the editor at large,
the InfoWars that I don't
speak to Paul, Joseph Watson,
he and I are friends,
I'm not gonna do that.
I can't be fake, right?
So if you think that some
condition of me saying,
well, Candace, you can
only stay mainstream
as if you pretend that
you don't speak to anybody
that's ever been
associated with InfoWars,
I'm not that, that's crappy
and conservatives need to
stop playing that game.
- Well also because so
many of these people,
and we see this all the time
and I won't out
people right now,
but that are privately
going to parties together
and going to dinners together,
but then won't
associate publicly--
- Right, I hate that, it's
fake, it's fraudulent.
And that's why you're seeing
this uprising by the way
of conservatives who are saying,
these are the neo-cons
and this is...
What they're really getting
at, and I don't agree with any,
a lot of their ideas is that
people are scared, right?
At the same time
that you're saying
you're fighting the Left,
you're playing by their games.
Okay, so if you're
gonna say that you,
you hate InfoWars, I
don't watch InfoWars
I've never watched
InfoWars, but you know,
because they're there
fraudulent and they're fake news
and all this stuff,
but you'll go on CNN.
I don't know how
that works, right?
If you go on a network
that routinely refers
to people as white supremacists,
Nazis and all of this stuff,
to me, I have my ideas,
these are my ideas
about black America.
Whether I'm speaking to you,
whether I'm speaking
to Paul Joseph Watson,
to Don Lemon,
and whether I'm speaking
to somebody on Fox News,
I'm the same Candace, right?
So the environment that I'm in
doesn't really matter for me
because I'm not
sanctioning their ideas.
If I go on CNN, I am not
agreeing with everything
Don Lemon has ever said,
if I am going on
the Rubin Report,
I am not saying that I
agree with everything
that you have ever said,
and conservatives
should stand by that.
That should be across the board.
Like it is okay to speak to
people that you disagree with.
You're not gonna catch something
if you talk to people
that you do not agree
with every single
thing that they say.
And that there's a
cowardice about that.
- Well also, you see
this crazy version
where putting whatever you
might think about InfoWars
and I also, I was on once.
I did Alex Jones once,
but I have literally
never watched it.
Even though I see these memes,
well, you don't see them anymore
because people are
afraid to get banned,
but you see memes
or the guy screaming
and gay frogs and the
rest of it, whatever.
It doesn't even matter.
But Trump gave his big
Coronavirus speech last night,
and I was watching CNN
because I do try occasionally
to flip through just to get
a feel of what's going on.
And CNN comes back
and it's Chris Cuomo
and Jim Mecosta and they
immediately go into Trump
within 30 seconds
of Trump's speech.
He gives the, probably
the most important speech
that presidents given in at
least a decade or something.
And they immediately go
to his xenophobic language
and it's like, guys,
that's not news.
- Right, it's not news.
- That's not news.
- I totally agree
and I think that--
- You guys, CNN, you were
calling it the Wuhan virus,
two weeks ago.
And now, because he says
from China, it's racist.
- Yeah. I mean, it's true.
And this is the environment
that we're in, unfortunately.
And I think that it's
incumbent for conservatives
not to play by the Left's rules.
And what I mean by that is even,
you know, I don't
watch InfoWars,
but I think that
pretending the Alex Jones
is this big villainous
character is wrong, it's wrong.
I think that we know
people watch him,
I assume from what
I've seen, the clips,
it's like the WWE of politics.
It's like making voices,
sounds, like entertainment.
You know what I mean?
And all of these, yeah,
to pretend that every
person that watches him,
is like some like a young,
white supremacist in training,
it's just irresponsible
and sloppy.
And I just try to be authentic
in terms of the way
that I view all people.
And I'm not going to
suddenly because I'm accepted
into the mainstream, you
know, to pretend that,
well, I'm not that
kind of concern.
I'm not that kind
of whoever it is.
And I think there's
been a lot of that
in the conservative movement.
And we need to stop that
sort of like Puritan,
I guess, a Puritan perspective
that I see a lot of people
are holding right now.
- So I wanna get into
some of the things
that we disagree on.
And we actually, I just
did your show yesterday
and we unearthed a lot of it
and hopefully we can take it
a little further right now,
but what do you make of the
never Trump conservatives
who are now suddenly...
They were like all
suddenly socialists.
Like it was like one
thing to be never Trump.
That could be your
position, so be it,
you don't like his attitude.
You don't like the way
he tweets the rest of it.
You may not like his policies
from a right perspective,
but they're suddenly all, like,
they kind of like Bernie now,
or they're like
all on team Biden.
It's like one thing
to be against one guy,
but how can you
be a conservative
and be for Biden or
something like that.
- Right, so here's
what I'll say.
So, and correct me if I'm wrong.
Glenn Beck used to
be a never Trumper.
- Glenn Beck, but
he was on the right.
Yeah, so Glenn Beck
was a never a Trumper--
- Yeah, yeah so I'm gonna
use Glen as an example
because I spoke to Glenn Beck.
I did a show a few weeks ago.
And what we talked about
when we were talking about
evolution and saying that like,
you know, there were tons of
people that were never Trump,
you know, good reasons
or bad reasons.
Like, you know, people
weren't sure about him,
myself included when he first
came down, the escalator,
the people that have kept
that up at this point
or have have said,
are just suffering from
extreme arrogance, right?
And then they kept it up so much
that they're now saying,
oh, I'd rather be on
the side of socialism.
You're basically saying that
you want so badly to be right
about this person that you
have been so against, right?
You've taken such a hard...
Drawn, such a hard line in
the sand about hating him.
That you're actually
willing to accept things
that you know,
will fundamentally
reverse the country
that you live in.
And that will fundamentally
break down the fabric
of America just so
you can be right.
I can think of no greater
example of narcissism.
- Yeah, it's just like
this perpetually endless...
Well also because the outrage,
it sort of goes to what
you were saying before.
It's like, they need
this endless outrage
to kind of keep this machine.
That's how they
define themselves.
So you need it.
And it's always a lot
easier to be the complainer
than the doer, like
that's it right there,
but all right, let's get
into some of the stuff
we talked about yesterday,
because you were asking
me, you're going Dave,
and I've heard it before.
Dave, what do you mean
you're still a liberal,
you're still a classical
liberal, come on,
you're a conservative.
And we unearthed some of that.
One of the things I said to
you is what I would love to see
a space for people on the right
and conservatives
or Republicans,
whatever you wanna call it,
to carve out some room for
sensible pro choice people.
And I don't really
see it right now.
And my position would not
be to try to convince people
on the right to be
more pro choice at all.
But I happen to agree
with people on the right
about most of the other things.
So I'd like to see a bit
of a wider tent there.
- Well, I hope that I have
carved out that space, you know,
because I felt the same way
when I became a conservative,
that it was like, you need
to say all of this instantly
and agree with all
of this instantly,
or you're not really a
conservative sort of a thing.
And I think that there needs
to be exactly what you said,
a wider tent, and we
can't become what we hate.
The Left puts everybody up
to these period of tests
and says, if you agree
with me, 99% of the time,
or you disagree with me 1%,
you're not allowed
to be on the boat.
And I need--
- Not just on the boat.
Now we have to drown.
- Now we have to
drown too, right.
- It's like we're gonna tie
some rocks to your feet.
- You gotta go overboard,
you gotta walk the plank.
And I think that we have to
be conscious as conservatives
not to do the exact same thing.
And I know that in terms
of the pro choice thing,
I have been a person that I
think has been more accepting
than anybody in the
conservative movement,
because you remember when
I was sitting on your show
and you first asked
me and I said,
I'm gonna kind of not say what
I think about this just yet,
because I wasn't ready.
And I didn't have my
opinions formulated
on the basis of fact yet.
My opinion is I'm pro-life.
And, but I know that there
are a lot of young women
who have made the decision...
This is what I was
struggling with.
I had so many friends
and family members
who had made the decision
to have an abortion.
And for me to then say that
they, you murdered your baby,
you're a horrible human
being, you're irredeemable,
It wouldn't be authentic.
And that's why I wasn't
ready to make that leap.
But instead, you know,
I had remarkable
conversation with a woman
and who is strongly pro-life
and had three abortions.
And she said that she had
her come to God moment,
where she realized that
she was doing this thing.
And she was having
these abortions
because she was a part of
a society that told her
it was a clump of cells.
So you're forgetting that
you have these young girls
who are, they don't want to
murder their offspring, right?
But they're growing
up in a society
that is mocking
making abortion seem
like it's a really easy process.
If you go in you're gonna
be fine, it's clump a cells,
you have the girls not
doing the TikTok videos,
making fun of like, you know,
how easy it is to
get an abortion.
You've got Miley Cyrus
and her abortion cake,
with her tongue out, half naked.
You've got Michelle
Williams on stage.
I think it's Michelle Williams
on stage accepting an award
and giving a speech
about how happy she is,
she killed her kid and
she's holding a trophy.
Well, this is what's raising
your kids, culture, right?
And so how can you fall
a young girl who goes in
and makes a decision
at 19 years old
to remove a clump of cells
and then tell her
she's irredeemable
and that she's a baby killer.
That's not creating room in
the conservative movement.
What you can say instead
is that, you know what?
You may have made that
mistake when you were young,
you may have done something
when you were young,
because you thought
you hadn't evolved.
And you thought that you were
making the right decision,
the best decision based
on societal pressure,
which tells you when
you're a young girl,
your whole life
is gonna be ruined
if you're not married,
you don't have all of your
finances just figured out
and you have a kid.
That's what you kind
of learn in school.
And this is the responsible
decision to get an abortion,
but you can change your mind
and you can actually be
one of the loudest voices
for pro-life.
It actually, it
holds more weight.
If you're somebody that's
converted away from it,
and similar to me being a
person that was a liberal
and converted away from it,
it actually holds more weight.
- So what if you actually
don't go that far
and you're still say more,
where I would say were
to me first trimester,
do I believe it to life?
Yes, because that clump of
cells you're talking about,
If we found it on the moon,
everybody would say
it's life, right?
So like I'm not playing
the life game in any way.
But do you think there is
room for people that would say
first trimester or
a couple of weeks,
or, you know, some
version of that,
we don't have to give
you an exact number,
in the conservative movement
that they don't view it
as necessarily wrong, but just
like an awful choice to make,
or that they worry about
whatever the health defects are
or health to the mother
or the rest of it.
- Right, so I think
first and foremost,
the most important
thing that you're doing
is you're acknowledging
it to life.
That already makes
things so much better.
Like if the Left
acknowledged it was a life
and taught that it was a life,
abortions would decrease,
no one would even be arguing
about it in Congress anywhere
because abortions would
magically decrease,
to a number that it was like,
not even a debate, right?
Because people would
suddenly realize it's baby
and I'm making it,
it's a heavier decision
because it is a baby that
I'm going in to
terminate a pregnancy.
There's a real living
thing inside of me.
So the education to me
is 90% of the battle.
The second point and talking
about people who abort,
because they have a
special needs child,
it would be really
crazy to say to people
who have responsibly
planned to have a child
and, you know, they've
saved up their money
and everything in the right way,
and they find out that their
child is going to require
much more money, much more
time to say to people like,
no matter what you
have to have...
This now what you have to do.
this is what God gave you.
Would you like to think that
in every scenario people say,
you know what?
This is what God gave.
This is you know, the
burden that God gave me,
or I don't mean to call a
child the burden, but like,
this is I guess, a
test or a struggle
that God is putting my
family through for a reason.
And when people do
that, it's incredible.
And it's beautiful,
but to expect rather
that every single person
is going to do that, to
have the means to do that,
especially when I know a person
who has a severely challenged
child physically and mentally,
aside from the financial burden
and not being able
to afford anything,
and the stress and the breaking
down people's relationships
and things of that nature,
their biggest fear is
that when they're done
taking care of their
child, no one else will,
that their child is
going to assist them.
And to tell a parent to
just accept that reality,
that when you die, 'cause
you aren't gonna die first,
that your child who is,
you know, in a wheelchair,
can't help themselves,
can't be feed themselves,
they can't do anything,
It is just supposed to, I guess,
be given to government and hope
that other people take care
of them.
It's a burden that
parents should just say,
okay, and give no thought to,
I don't think that's realistic.
- Oh, and by the way,
conservatives don't
want those programs too.
So if you were to allow people
to have certain abortions
up to a certain point, or no,
if you were to tell people
that they can't have abortions
at all, do you think the state
then has a responsibility
to take care of more
of those children?
'Cause that's a tough one
for conservatives, right?
- That's a tough one.
Do they have a responsibility?
Well, if it became a law--
- If abortion, if Roe
V Wade was flipped
at all of the
states suddenly said
abortion is illegal period.
Now people start
having abortions.
And first off we know like
the uncomfortable facts
about this are that people
of a certain economic level,
we'll still get abortions
in a safe manner.
They will be ways.
Will some people that aren't
economically able to do it,
do it in back alleys,
and the hangers,
and all the horrible stories?
Of course.
So you create this weird
economic thing also.
But if the state was to say
no more abortions, period,
does the state then
have a responsibility,
I guess, from a
conservative perspective
to help these people?
- Well, I guess the first--
- I don't know that I've
ever heard a good answer.
- I think the good
answer is that the state
is already doing that.
The state is already,
when you're talking
about what having a child
is gonna be a
financial burden...
And I'm talking about
healthy children.
This is what I
really disagree with.
Like the healthy child
and people are just like
inconvenient, throw it away,
inconvenient, throw it away.
I mean, look at the
welfare system right now.
And the various
people that we support
and take care of, and all
of these different things.
So pretending that this is
gonna be like, you know,
one more kid that
gets a welfare check
and which I'm
against, by the way,
I don't think you should be
raising people's children
and paying for these things.
And the economic
argument here is that
when the government actually
stops taking all of our money,
and giving it to all
these various programs,
it's been proven that
people give more,
people are more
inclined to do charity.
Who gives more to
autistic causes,
than people that have
autistic children, right?
People whose parents
have suffered or
died from Alzheimer's
are the ones that
are most inclined
to get to Alzheimer's research.
I think that we've gotten
into a place in society
where we don't realize
how charitable people are
when they're not being robbed
blindly by the government.
So I'd like to think
that as a community,
people would wanna take
care of one another,
especially people
that have lived through
those situations before,
there'll be more inclined
to take care of one another.
But that's a way bigger question
that requires more
thought of like,
if you start forcing people to
have special needs children,
if they were going
to abort it because--
- Not even special
needs children,
if someone just wanted
to have an abortion
and the state said you can't,
and then they forced that
person to bring the baby to term
what is the state's
responsibility?
So it could be someone with--
- Well, typically you
have children that grew up
in group homes that---
- So it's happening already?
- Yeah, it's already happening,
yeah that's already
built into the system
because there are some tons
of people who just morally
don't wanna have abortions.
There are tons of children
that make young girls
who make that decision
and their stories
are just not covered.
I knew a girl who I worked with
when I was interning at Vogue
and she had already had a child
and she gave it up for adoption
because she morally as a
Christian did not believe
in having an abortion.
Beautiful little girl, she
has a relationship with her
and she just was not
ready to be a mother.
I actually think that
one of the biggest things
that we need to start
fixing and addressing
is our adoption system.
Have you talked to any parent
that wants to adopt the child?
It's like impossible.
It's like they can't,
they gotta jump through
10,000 different hoops.
By the time you thought
you were gonna have a baby,
now you've got a ten-year-old,
'cause it took 10 years to
go through the paperwork
to be able to adopt a child.
So that would be, I think
an area of interest for me
is looking at what
is the system,
if you want to adopt a child.
And why is it so complicated
when we know that there
are tons of people
that are having children,
healthy children
that necessarily don't know if
they wanna take care of them?
- What do you say to all
people that are like,
oh yeah, it sounds right.
You should just stop
all the programs
and stop the food stamps,
and stop the
government assistance,
and the subsidized
housing, and section seven
and blah, blah, blah.
Yeah, it sounds right.
You should just stop it.
But, you rip that bandaid off
and then all hell breaks loose.
We've talked about this
a little bit before,
because that's where I
always see people say,
ah, she doesn't get it.
You know, these people
are gonna suddenly be all
out on the streets at once.
- No, I'm so against
the welfare system.
I mean, I am fully
against the welfare system
that has nothing
but hindered people.
We've learned a lesson
over and over again.
If you incentivize
people to do nothing,
they will do nothing.
And that is exactly what
the welfare system does.
It needs to be revamped.
It needs to be corrected.
I mean, rip it off
like a bandaid.
Probably the best
'cause people know
nothing's there to support them.
They're gonna figure it out.
That is human nature, right?
If you know a check
is not gonna come,
You're gonna figure out
how you're going to eat.
- Right, I've heard people say,
well, over a course of a year,
you could slowly keep
reducing benefits.
But I suspect that most people
just because it's human nature,
it has nothing to do with
skin color or anything else.
Will still keep the same habits
thinking that at the end,
it will start coming back again.
'Cause that's what the
government always does.
You know what I mean?
- You think so?
- Yeah, I think if you
slowly take it away
that people actually won't
change their habits really.
- I think they will.
- I think, yeah?
- I think they would.
And I say this as
somebody who has family.
- I was giving you the
argument for rip it off,
because it almost seems
like the shock and all
is almost the only way to do it.
- Yeah, I guess that
I was misunderstanding
what you were saying there,
because what I was saying is
that if you said to people,
when they went on welfare,
you only got it for one year
and that's, it it's over.
They would have in their
head, that timeline,
I got one year I got a
little bit of playroom
and I gotta get off of welfare.
The problem is that
it's perpetual.
- Well, that's what I mean.
It's almost like it's
gone on for so long
that they wouldn't even believe
the government
would ever stop it.
So like you get the
paper and the paper says,
well guys starting
today, you know,
we've been doing
this for 12 years,
but every month we're
cutting, you know,
10% until it's gone.
They just be like, nah,
it's not happening.
And then most likely
the government caves,
because people will get
on, politicians get on TV.
And then you see what they're
doing to these mean people
they're doing to these people,
it's the mean Republicans.
- Yeah, it's gotta be
something that someone does
in their second term.
(both laugh)
you know what I mean?
Sorry, nothing you can do here.
It's just happening.
But yeah, there
definitely needs to be
just a complete revision of
the welfare system as it is.
And I'm not saying that
there aren't some people
that actually have
legitimate claims to health.
It's just, I'm
saying that there,
maybe there's not some people
that have legitimate claims
needing an abortion,
for medical emergencies
and things of those nature.
But when it becomes the norm,
the overwhelming majority of
people are taking advantage
and making horrible decisions
and placing a burden on people
like me and you who get up and
have to work every single day
and somehow have to
support their lifestyles
of, oh, I, every time
I have another baby,
I get another check.
That's incentivizing
bad behavior.
I'm just gonna
keep having babies,
knowing I can't afford them.
That's the whole reason I'm
on welfare in the first place.
But knowing that the government
will give me more and more
money, it's just, honestly,
it's just human behavior.
- Does it also strike you
as like a sort of very dim
and depressing view
of what humans are
that unless the government
forces us to do things,
we'll never do anything
good for people.
You know what I mean?
Like there are
charities that I give to
that I don't run
around screaming about,
or I try to do some
good things in my life
and treat my employees
right and the rest of it,
'cause I believe
that it's on you
versus like these people
that think if we don't demand
that the state does everything,
no one will do anything good.
You're actually saying
much more about yourself
than you're saying
about people in general.
- Right, and they're wrong.
I mean, you can literally look
at when the taxes are lower,
Americans give more, but
when the taxes are higher,
Americans give less
and that's because
they're having their own
money taken away from them.
So they can think
that all they want,
but they're fundamentally wrong.
And I don't think
that the majority of
them even think that,
especially not the leaders
and the politicians.
I think that you just,
especially on the socialist
side of the argument
and the Bernie
Sanders and the AOCs,
I think they genuinely just
want power for themselves.
And the best people to
make a plea for power
are people that
are impoverished.
And don't have that
self confidence to
believe in themselves
to go to them and say, your
life is not your fault,
you know, it makes
them feel better.
Oh, that's right,
it's not my fault.
It's not my fault that I had
five kids out of wedlock--
- It also makes them
such heroes, right?
I mean, AOC is such a hero.
Bernie is such a hero.
He can help all these people,
never accomplished
anything, but.
- They help all those people
and they get behind them,
and it's just easy
votes for them
because people at the
end of the day, are lazy.
If you tell them they
don't have to do anything
and they don't want
to do anything,
they're not going
to do anything.
So it's an easy
political strategy.
But I think what I
try to tell people
is that if you just wait, right?
If you just go through
the hard work and yes,
it's not gonna be easy,
'cause life is not easy
and we're all struggling
and you can have a
bad day tomorrow,
even in the midst of
having a great year.
But if you just wait and
you put a little bit in
and a little bit more in,
and you do this everyday,
day in and day out,
that feeling that you get
when you accomplish something,
the feeling that I have right
now sitting across from you,
knowing that I now run
two businesses by myself.
And I started my life as a girl
in a roach infested apartment,
you wouldn't trade that
feeling for the world.
The government can't
do that for you.
That feeling of accomplishment.
And that's what I think
is being taken away
from individuals,
knowing how good it feels when
you get to the finish line.
- Ah, that's good.
We should end there, but
we're not ending there.
(laughing)
But that was the right ending.
Let's just do a couple
more of those sort of
what the conservatives can do
to maybe be a little more open
that we talked
about on your show.
So one of them was marijuana.
So I told you, my feeling is
that marijuana should be legal.
I don't care if
the states do it.
I'd prefer not the federal
government to do it.
'Cause I think it should
be a state's rights issue.
And if Colorado passes it and
you know, you don't like it,
then you can move
somewhere else.
And if you move somewhere
else and they don't have it
and you want it to move to
Colorado and the rest of it,
that's how I like the
American experiment to work.
Most conservatives are
pretty much against
legalizing marijuana at
either level, excuse me.
And they sort of take
this odd approach
because you would think that
they would want the government
out of people's lives.
How do you sorta arbitrage that?
- First and foremost,
there seems to be a disconnect
with a lot of conservatives
about the effects of marijuana.
I know like I've
spoken to some people
who have never smoked
marijuana in their life.
And I'm actually, I'm thinking
of someone I used to date
who had never smoked
marijuana in his life.
And what was really
interesting about it
is that he had it in the
same category as like heroin.
Like I was just impressed
with how wrong he was,
about what people do,
when they smoke a joint,
like he thinks, I don't know,
maybe it's like a
methamphetamine.
They get up, they go rob,
shoot at a gas station,
rob people.
And the truth is, is that it
makes people, in my opinion,
impotent, they sit on couches.
They wanna eat a bunch.
They're laughing,
they watch movies,
but definitely not going
out and committing crimes
and things of that nature.
I think the
conservative argument
is that it's a gateway drug.
I think I've heard a
lot of people say that.
- They love that argument.
- And I just where I have--
- But then it's like, well,
alcohol is a gateway drug also.
- That's what I
was gonna get at.
So I had this debate with
Rick Santorum, actually,
he was sitting next to me
and he was talking about
the marijuana thing and
I actually didn't really
have a stance on it, I just
liked to engage my brain
and debate people when I
think that they have something
that's fundamentally
missing in their argument,
and he was drinking
glass of wine
and saying that marijuana
should permanently be banned
because of its bad effects.
And I said, well,
how do you reconcile that
with you drinking wine?
And you know, I go
years in and out
with not drinking alcohol.
I'm not drinking alcohol this
year, didn't drink alcohol
when you met me and--
- You had one good
year in there though--
- My wedding year.
(indistinct chatting)
- We had a good time.
- You can't not drink when
you're getting married.
'Cause everybody
gives you alcohol.
It's the only gift you
get for a whole year
until you get married.
But so I am saying that,
I'm seeing him drink
this glass of wine
and I'm wondering how
he's reconciling it.
And he says, oh, well
this is different.
Well, tell me how
it's different.
Well, alcohol, it's
different for me.
If I'm drinking
alcohol at my house.
And I'm like, well, that's
exactly their argument
for smoking pot.
And I said, naturally,
if you wanna talk about having
a worse impact on society,
alcohol causes way more deaths.
People get drunk, they go
home, they beat their wives.
They party, they make mistakes.
You know, it is a gateway drug.
- Car accident.
- Car accidents.
The car accident
happened from DUIs,
which is higher than by the way,
people that are killed
by guns every year.
Look at the deaths
by motor vehicles.
Nobody's talking about
taking people's cars away.
We don't want to
give in our cars.
But so I said that to him
and I think he was starting
to see, I was like,
if you're gonna
make that argument,
you need to make the
argument more soundly
because you either are a person
that believes that
there should be...
You abstain from everything,
and that society is just
better off without everything.
Or if you're saying that people
should have the, you know,
the right, the personal
right to engage in drinking
and getting blacked
out drunk at bars
so long as they don't
drive themselves home,
then you're gonna have
a hard time arguing
that people shouldn't
have the same right
when it comes to pot.
- Right, and it's funny
because for someone like me,
it's like, well, I see the
conservative perspective
is conservatives really wanna do
what they think in the
longterm over generations
is good for a sound and
secure and safe society.
I'm not saying marijuana
is for it or against it.
I mean, I've told you I
smoked weed maybe once a week,
I watched the
Simpsons at 11 o'clock
and I pass out on the
couch, I don't hurt anybody.
I have never robbed
a bank on weed.
And I probably do eat
too much popcorn on weed.
That would be like the
one thing, you know.
But, so I understand
their argument of like,
but if you just tell
people that this is okay,
then they'll go, oh,
something else is okay.
Or this is okay, but you
can't stop human nature.
And for the same people
that don't wanna
legislate a lot of stuff,
I think it's just a
dangerous spot to be in.
- Yeah, I don't smoke pot.
And I say to people, I
would recommend people,
not smoking pot.
'Cause it just, I think
it kills ambition.
Like some people are
different, you know,
people like you who are like,
I can smoke and go
to bed and get up
and do what I have
to do the next day.
But I think overwhelmingly
it kills ambition.
Now as a free market
capitalism, I'm fine with that.
'Cause I'll crush
the competition.
- Yeah, that's the answer.
- Yeah, I'll crush
the competition.
So if you wanna smoke
your pot and stay in bed,
I'm gonna go run the world.
But yeah, I think it's hard.
I think it's really tricky.
And I understand that
argument of like,
well then they'll be
looking for the next thing,
they'll be looking
for the next thing,
once you say that's
okay and that's true,
but I just don't see,
I don't see how I could
make a sound argument
when people are okay
with drinking alcohol.
- So you would basically
kick it to the states,
which is sort of where
it's at right now--
- And then there's the other
argument where I said to him,
and by the way, I
was just saying this
for the sake of
arguing, you know?
'Cause I just like
to debate ideas.
I said, do you think
that legislating it,
did it stop people
from smoking pot?
It didn't actually,
it didn't say,
I don't know any person
that I went to college with
that did not smoke pot.
So when it was illegal,
it wasn't like people
weren't doing it.
- Right, and the
funny part is now,
I don't know if there's...
There must be some
studies on this,
but now that it's
legal by states,
like I doubt many more
people are smoking weed
because it suddenly got legal,
'cause it was so
ubiquitous everywhere,
you could get it anywhere.
So I don't think suddenly
somebody was like, well,
it's legal, I'm gonna smoke pot.
- That's right,
everyone that I knew
was smoking pot before
it, and by the way,
most of them ended up
stopping at a certain age.
And because it became legal,
didn't make them go and now
I'm gonna go out and do it.
So it's like when I first
drank, I wasn't 21 years old,
you know what I'm saying?
So the legality of it
being 21 years old,
that'll come back to haunt me
when they dig this
up 30 years from now.
The legality of it
say, the law saying
that I can't drink until I'm 21,
did nothing to stop
me from drinking.
Well, before I was 21.
I mean, I drank in high school.
I drank when I was 15 years old,
14, 15 years old, literally.
So it was the first
time that I got drunk
and I continued to drink.
Somebody's older
brother or sister
would buy us a pack of beer
and do all that nature.
So the idea that what's
bad about that concept
is the idea that like, if
suddenly it becomes legal,
suddenly people
will get in line.
It's just a faulty argument
because we already know
that people don't
follow the laws, right?
- George Carlin has a funny
line on pot, which is like,
he's like most drugs,
you do them and you want
more and more and more,
pot like you're like smoking
and one day you're like,
okay, I've had enough of that.
You know, like, that's
pretty much enough of that.
Okay, so we talked abortion,
we talked marijuana.
The other one we talked about
was sort of a carving a space
for secular conservatives.
And I'm really curious about
this space because I've had...
Have you talked to Heather
MacDonald on your show yet
from the Manhattan Institute?
She's a great free market
capitalist and thinker--
- Yeah I know her well she
did a lot of great work on--
- Diversity delusion, yeah.
So you should
definitely talk to her
and I'll connect you guys.
And she's wonderful.
She is a secular conservative.
She's been an atheist or
agnostic her entire life.
She said she was never believer.
She was brought up in
a totally secular home
and she thinks that there's
a strong secular argument
for conservatism.
Most conservatives
don't really think that.
I would love to see,
and you know I've had
my own sort of spiritual
awakening where I am a believer
and I certainly believe
for a society to organize,
more than anything else
that it has to have
some underlying set of beliefs.
And our founders talked
about God given rights
and the rest of it.
Do you think there
is space for that?
'Cause I feel like this one
makes a lot of conservatives
nervous like that they
would let them in,
these godless
people or something
and that they're
gonna somehow rattle
the whole thing or
something like that.
- Yeah, I definitely don't think
they're gonna rattle anything.
I think actually when
you want to invite people
into the conservative movement,
they'll naturally, I think
they'll naturally tread towards
spiritualism and here's why.
You can't say that you believe
in Western civilization
without acknowledging
that there would be no
Western civilization
without Judeo-Christian beliefs.
Judeo-Christian beliefs is
what brought the world forward.
Any studying of,
of Western society
brings you right back to, you
know, the early Greek miracle
and what was the Greek miracle?
It was an understanding, a
move away from the tribalism
that naturally followed a
polytheistic worldview, right?
So when the world used
to believe in polytheism,
when everybody thought
there was a rain God
and the sun God, and a
God for your illness,
whatever it was, they
were naturally more tribal
because they'd sacrifice.
I'm gonna kill 26 kids a
sacrifice to the rain God today.
And there was no sense.
There was no sense of reasoning.
There was no morality because
everything was all crikey,
the rain, God must
be pissed off.
You know, I must sacrifice
this goat to the rain God,
or oh, crikey our
crops are dried out.
I must sacrifice this.
And there was no
thought process.
And then the Greek
miracle happened,
you know, this
concept of freedom
where people started to
think more and philosophize.
And we had those
early philosophers,
you know, Plato, Aristotle,
Socrates, who started saying,
what if there's just one?
What if it's one God?
And one of my actions
actually matter,
what if morality matters?
That was the beginning,
that was the breakthrough
where they started to
really start to believe
in freedom, right?
And they developed this
monotheistic worldview,
and it reshaped everything.
It is literally the
beginning of Western society
that happened with
that Greek miracle.
And then what then
transpired beyond that,
was once they started
to realize that, wow,
like maybe, there
is a higher power
and maybe my actions do matter.
They naturally
started to say, wow,
then that means we have
to question everything
that we've ever done
that was a immoral.
And they eventually got
to the concept of slavery,
which was done
everywhere in the world
until they had started
thinking about,
once the Christian people led
the world in ending slavery
because they said
there was no longer..
There can not be a moral
ground for slavery.
It matters, my actions matter.
And that was why we saw
a slave get abolished
led first by the
French colonies.
I think a French colonies were
first followed by Britain,
followed by America.
You know, the old white
men, the terrible white men,
they led the world
ending slavery.
And that was the
reason why, right?
So if you fundamentally
understand why the
West is the best,
why the West is great, how
the West became the West,
then you do know that
you can't untether that
from Judeo-Christian belief.
So I think that it's,
you invite them in,
you can be atheistic and you
can be conservative, right?
But if you really understand
what you're trying to conserve.
When you get, and you
start doing the work,
which I had to
do, which is like,
I know that I'm conservative.
What is conservatism?
What am I working to conserve?
What I'm working to
conserve is Western society.
What I'm working to conserve
is the idea of freedom.
What I'm working to conserve,
is that early Greek
miracle that happened.
And I cannot tether that
from Judeo-Christian belief.
- Men, you're
getting good at this.
- Little bit of work, you
know, you gotta read some books
and really not just ask
yourself what you believe,
but ask yourself
why you believe it.
- All right, so
speaking of books,
I don't have a copy
of "Blackout" here
because the galleys
have not arrived yet,
- They have not arrived.
- The galleys are on the way.
I know that a lot of
what we discussed here
obviously is what
"Blackout" is about,
but what maybe did I miss?
Or should we hit on?
- You know, so "Blackout"
for me, it was,
I really wanted to
first and foremost,
lay out my personal story.
There's been a lot of conjecture
about where I came from,
how I became a conservative,
is she a fraudulent conservative
and all of that craziness
because people don't realize
that I just was apolitical,
if anything else.
- To be clear, you're not
some sort of secret agent.
- No, you really have been
there through all of it.
- I've been there
since the beginning.
- I mean, the YouTubers like
digesting my entire life
saying like, she must
be a plant, like,
I mean a soulless plant.
I'm like, I've never even voted.
Like I literally prior
to getting into things
I genuinely just was not
politically inclined.
And I just thought I
had to be a Democrat
and thought I had
to be a liberal.
And, you know, looking
in the retrospect,
I realized how foolish
that is, you know,
that I didn't realize that
everything was really...
That everything that
bad happened in my life
was really routed to bad
policies and bad politicians.
But I wanted to first lay
out just my personal story.
You know, the subtitle
of the book is
"How Black America Can
Make it's Second Escape
"From the Democrat Plantations."
And I do believe, I
say this all the time,
people get upset,
that black Americans are
still enslaved today,
that the Left just got smarter.
And they realized that
you can't enslave people,
their bodies, you can't
have black Americans
on the plantation anymore,
but you can still have black
Americans doing all the work
for you and reaping no benefit.
And that is a structure
that we see today
between black America
and the Democratic Party.
We are doing all the work,
we carried them
over the finish line
and we benefit not
in one single way.
And so I really kind of
lay out that argument
and talk about what slave
life was really like,
the breakdown of family,
why it was necessary for
families to be broken down,
to trade constantly
be trading slaves
from one plantation to
the next to the next,
they could have no
feelings for one another.
And Frederick Douglas
in his autobiography,
the first couple of pages,
when he starts talking
about his life as a slave.
He talks about the fact
that when his mother died,
he felt nothing.
When the sisters were
traded, he felt nothing,
he had no sense of kinship.
No familial love
for his own blood.
That was necessary to the
institution of slavery.
We still have that kinship
and that relationship
and that community
still broken down
all of these years later,
despite the reconstruction
era post-slavery,
which we saw black American
families getting back together,
we were doing something.
It's all been wiped away.
- At a higher rate, by the
way, until about 72 or so.
- In the 1950S, black
Americans were outpacing whites
in terms of economic growth.
And then immediately
following, the 1960s
and the Great Society Act
and the systemic oppression,
which started via
the welfare system,
everything started
falling apart.
And reading another topic,
going back to slavery.
Black Americans, it was
illegal for black Americans
to learn how to read.
In fact, it was so illegal that
if you were a white person,
and you were caught
teaching your slave to read,
you would be found guilty
too, it was a serious sin.
The reason for that is because
they didn't want Black people
being educated because an
educated mind can't be enslaved.
Well, what's changed?
And look at the literacy
rates in black America today.
Look at Baltimore, look
at the inner cities.
Look at we're in California.
At California, 70% of
black boys could not pass
the basic literacy exam.
Nobody's talking about that.
You have politicians that
are standing on stage
saying that all they care
about is black Americans.
They're not talking
about everything
that is harming black
Americans today.
Everything that is recreating
the very same plantations
that we came from.
- Did you catch that
brilliant line that Bernie had
in one of the debates,
which is he wants,
he's not only so pro marijuana,
that he wants it to be legal,
but he also wants to have
black business owners,
owning black marijuana
shops in black communities.
- Right, I did not
catch that line.
- And again, I say
this as someone
that's pro legalizing
weed, but like,
we're gonna incentivize
black people
to own black marijuana shops
in black communities that...
- Right, and that's why I
don't celebrate by the way,
why I am conservative
on the marijuana front
is because when you talk
about where this is happening,
Chicago, I think just
passed marijuana laws.
It is to me, I know it's going
to lead to more dysfunction,
you know, amongst black
America, first and foremost.
'Cause that's how it always is.
You know, it's what is it
about progressive policies
that always leads to
regressive results
for the black community
first and foremost.
And so I am loathed
to be smart enough
to see the debate between
alcohol and marijuana
so that I can't firmly say--
- I get you, I get you.
- But I have a thinking brain
and I just don't see
how conservatives
can make a sound argument
against it at the moment.
- What else has to happen for
the black community to break?
I'm gonna guess, although
I don't have the book yet,
that at the end, you either
make some predictions
or you tell people
what tools they need
to really break out of this.
- Yeah, you know, it's not
even about making predictions
and I have my own
personal predictions,
but I definitely I'm not
doing that in the book.
I'm giving black
Americans a guide.
Americans and option,
the same option
that I saw before me
when I started waking up
and I'm having this
conversation with you.
You can have the option to
accept this victim narrative,
You can have the option to say,
I accept this diagnosis of
cancer, even though I feel fine,
walk fine and have been
living fine my entire life.
I accept that it's
terminal illness
and I'm gonna live like
I'm gonna die any moment
or you can develop a
different perspective
and you can develop a
victor mentality, as I say.
Forget the victim mentality,
develop a victor mentality.
Look back at your ancestors,
look back at your grandparents,
look back at what they did,
what they lived through,
the seeds that they planted,
so that you can afford
to be in the circumstance
that you are in today.
If you are a black American
and you are breathing in
the United States today,
you are the luckiest, among
the luckiest of Black people
that have ever lived anywhere
on the face of the planet.
That is an incredible statement.
All of human history,
the luckiest Black people
that have ever lived on the
face of the human planet
are the ones that are living
and breathing in America today.
Okay, if you understand that
and you should understand
it by simply saying,
where would you like
to live in Africa?
For all of that hoopla about
they took us from Africa,
find me a black American
that will tell you
they wanna move back to Africa.
I will listen right now --
- Or Europe.
- I'll book the flights
for them, right?
For any person that says we
were stolen from our ancestors,
I can assign words in pledging
that I will book the flights,
if you renounce
your US citizenship
for you to go live
back in Africa.
- You want a cap this
to maybe 10 people
just in case people
are punking you.
- No, no, there's none.
We did this, we repeated the
same phrases with the Trump,
I hate America.
Everyone offered them
money and flights.
I think you might
have, Don might have,
nobody took the bait, right?
Because know America
is the greatest place
they could possibly live.
- You know what,
if someone takes you up on this,
I'll guarantee one
first class upgrade.
- That's amazing.
- I will do that.
- There we go right here,
one first class upgrade.
To leave America but you have
to renounce your citizenship
to America and move to Africa.
That's really what you wanna do.
And look, you look
at Africa today,
this whole concept
that we were taken
and we were kings and
queens like this weird myth,
like this Disney story,
this Disney fairytale
that we were all running
around kings and queens
and enjoying the crops
and the fertile land
and all that we had.
And then evil white men
came with their guns.
- Wait you're telling me
Wakanda is not a place?
- This is really what the
story has come down to.
When in fact we were sold
by our own ancestors.
We were already living
in terrible situations.
We were already slaves.
We were already being enslaved.
We were enslaved
first by the Arabs.
The Arabs were the first
two enslave Africans.
And we were sold for
things as meaningless.
Talk about how, how
tribal their society was.
We were sold for gin.
We were sold from mirrors.
Imagine Africa look a mirror.
Oh, I'll take 20 of
my strongest men.
Thanks for the mirror.
Take 20 of my strongest men.
These are the reasons
that we were sold.
This is how tribal and how
backwards their society was.
Take ownership of that.
Take ownership of the fact that
when you look at
human history, I mean,
you look at all of the horrible
things that have happened,
nobody's guiltless,
least of all,
people that are in Africa
because today the slave
trade still goes on.
The slave trade still goes
on in the Subsaharan region.
The very same region that
black Americans descended from,
they are still being enslaved.
They're in a midst
of a nasty civil war.
There was child slavery.
There's child labor,
there's people that are
being sold to sex rings.
And this is the
situation of child slaves
in Ghana today that are
working along Lake Volta,
something like 30,000 of them.
CNN actually did a report
on it last year, you know,
'cause one of them had
escape and he talked about
how they would be beat.
And he said he was beat so bad
that he wished that
he was never born.
If they were caught
trying to eat the food,
this still goes on in that
place that you keep glorifying,
that you keep pretending that
the worst that ever happened
was that our ancestors
were brought to America.
By and large, you can look
back on that and realize,
and while certainly wasn't
in the circumstance back then
it is today that
it was a blessing.
In the retrospect,
it was a blessing
that we got out of Africa and
that we are in America today,
which is why so many of Africans
are trying to immigrate
to America today.
- On that note, Candace Owens.
I'm so proud of you.
Like on the professional
level, I'm just proud of you,
but on a personal level,
like it's just like, I know you,
like, I know you
are the real deal
and you have relentlessly
lived up to everything
that you have said,
and you're just
gonna keep going.
And it's just a--
- Well, I thank you, and
I really do mean this,
like being on your
show the first time,
I'm so happy that
it was your show,
that I sat down
across from first
because you didn't push me.
You didn't say you need
to know everything,
you have a stance on
everything Candace,
you just accepted that I
was authentically saying,
I've wanna learn, right?
And I've done that.
And I've tried to
remain authentic
and it's thanks to people
like you that create a space
like you were talking about
for people to be able to learn,
to be able to grow
and to not feel
like they need to be tribal
in their political beliefs.
I feel that I've been able
to grow and feel confident
in what I actually
do believe in today.
- I'll go with that.
I know you're
following her already,
but it's @RealCandaceOwen
on Twitter.
Thanks for watching.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlists,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.